Ever seen this map.
This is how the earth luck 200 million years ago before pangea the only super
continent on the planet came apart.
What if one day the continence join together into one giant land mass again and
you could travel from North America to Africa on foot?
What country would become your new neighbor with this caused natural disasters
all over the planet?
How long would this new pangea last for?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if the continence merged together.
Did you know the land below you is actually moving right now?
This is because all seven continents sit on the tectonic plates that Earth's
crust is broken into.
These plates are floating on Molten rock at the same speed your fingernails
grow.
It may sound slow,
but it does add up over hundreds of millions of years in the four and a half
billion year history of earth.
Our comments have changed their appearance many times,
sometimes fusing together and crunching collisions and sometimes breaking apart.
Right now they're slowly moving toward another collision.
What if one day they suddenly sped up and smashed into a super continent?
Again,
would you wake up to find yourself at the Mexican border?
The world would look very different than what you're used to.
If the plates collided in the direction you're moving.
Now,
the flight from Australia to Asia would never be cheaper.
Since Australia would collide with Japan,
Korea,
and China,
the two continents would no longer be separated by the Atlantic Ocean,
and if you're really into walking,
you'd also be able to travel from Sunny Australia to the world's coldest
continent of Antarctica on foot North America would bump into western Africa.
Citizens of New York might wake up to find the Namibian lions roaming through
central park.
The northern part of Africa would crash into Europe.
This would create a new Himalayan scale mountain range on the border of the
tectonic plates.
Okay,
thank camels would enjoy a chilly day on a snow hill.
Some of these changes may sound fun,
but there would be some really bad news to the eastern side of the Americas
along with Western Europe and Africa would turn into an earthquake danger zone.
On top of that,
these areas would be devastated by the eruptions of newly foreign volcanoes.
Green slopes of the Appalachians would become giant snow covered mountains
spewing ash and lava.
Yeah.
This new pangea would be mostly arid and hot as rain.
Clouds would lose most of their moisture before getting too far inland.
The supercontinent would be centered at the equator.
Wildlife would become less diverse as not all species can bear hot temperatures,
but just like the most recent continental Mashup,
this reunion wouldn't last forever.
Well not longer than 50 million years.
Volcanic eruptions would be spewing out large amounts of lava and gas.
I devastating earthquakes to the equation,
and you'd see these dangerous regions start to pull themselves apart and stirred
by hot currents below.
The supercontinent would eventually break apart into smaller continents going
their separate ways.
If bordering Australia looks like a cool thing to you,
bad luck.
You won't see this happening anytime soon,
but you can always imagine how the world would look if the giant continental
pieces of the puzzle came together.
Give the planet 300 million years and they'll be another supercontinent.
Geologists already gave it a name Pangea Ultima.
Okay.
What would you name it.